その主縁にはいくらかが
いくらか理解できるんですね
いわゆる主であることは条件なんですね
まあまあ そこら辺にはまあわかると思いますね
例えば我々の日常生活の中で
いつでも私達の生き方はまあそういう風になるでしょうに
何か他のやらなくちゃいけないことがあっても
それをやらないで他のことをやっている
その他のやっていることが自分にとってはもっと大事になるというか
この主になってしまうわけです
いろいろ例で考えればわかりやすいと
例えばこの受験勉強しなくちゃいけない人が
そこでその子がまあ学校で好きな人に振られたとする
そこで自分が受験勉強しなくちゃいけないんだけど
あのしょっぱなし頭に入ってしまって
もう本には勉強には頭が行かないんですね
集中力は行かないんですね
まあそれはそれで勉強すると思ったって
またそれを思い浮かんだりする
ですから なぜそういうことを思い浮かんだり考えるかというと
そちらがあの力強いインパクト強いんですね
それで頭がそこら辺に行ってしまっちゃう
それは主縁なんですね
そういうのを常に我々の認識過程の中でいつでもあることなんですね
私たちは何を認識しているかというと
やっぱり主縁を認識しちゃうんですね
今聞いてる もう何を聞いてるかと
私のことを音を聞いてるかもしれませんだけど
まあここに実際にあるのは私の音だけですかね
いろんな音あるでしょうに
いろんな音あるんだけど
全部聞いてないんです
聞いてない音はいっぱいあるんです
耳を澄ませて聞けば聞こえるはずなんです
でも聞いてない だから主縁だけ聞いてるんです
と アディペティパッチャヤ
えーと 次にはアナンタラパッチャヤ
アナンタラっていうのはアンっていうのは否定形でアンタラっていうのは間という意味なんですね
間がないんだと 無間 無間
無間 陰ですかね 無間陰のどっちでもあそがいいんですけど
無間陰って何でしょうかね
それもこの心と物質の変化を見て
この変化の過程そこで説明しているんですね
変化には間がないと だから一つ終わると次のことも起きているんです
だから一つの終わりと一つの現象の終わりと次の現象のあれこれがもう間
間がないんだと 例えば紙を燃やすと灰になる
どれぐらい間がありますか？間がないでしょう
紙を燃やしていくと同時に灰が生まれていくんですね
紙を燃やして分経ったところで灰が現れたということはないんです
ですから 物事の変化の場合は間がないんだと
[笑い]時々間があるように錯覚するときもありますけど
卵 ヒヨコになるためにはまあ三週間かかります
あるいは 1ヶ月とどれくらいか分かりませんですけど
とにかくそのその卵によって違いますからね
まあ一応 例えばまあ 1ヶ月間ちゃんと何て言いますか
温めておかないとヒヨコになれない
そうすると  1ヶ月とか卵が 1ヶ月間経ったところでパッとヒヨコになったというふうな感じがするんだけど
あれは錯覚なんです その間がないんです
だから卵を産んだその瞬間からも変化していくんですね
間なしにずっと変化していくんですね
だから何の間もないんです
で 私は例えば窓ガラスに石を投げると
投げたらもうそれに当たって
それから割れ目が入って窓ガラス割れて落ちるんだと
それにはまあ 1分経ったところで落ちる可能性もありますけど
1 分間間隔があったと
それはそうじゃないんです
それはそれはただ錯覚であって
じゃあ窓 窓ガラスに石を投げた瞬間で
じゃあそれだったらもうガラス破片落ちたかというと
そういうことでもなくて
石を石が石を当てられ
石が当てたと まあそれからヒビが入って
それなきのいろいろ原因がありますから
それなりにじわじわとこれ割れて
いろいろ他の条件 原因によってまあぽちぽちと落ちてくるんですね
ですから あの人間がこの間隔考える場合ありますけどね
それはもう時間の間を無視して考えるだけのことなんですね
もみをまいたらもう 3ヶ月間経ったところで刈ることできるんだと
やっぱり 3ヶ月間かかりますよと言っても
それは刈るもみと植えるもみの後の現象 2つしか考えてないんだから
3ヶ月間かかりますけどね
でも現象から次の現象を考えちゃうと間隔がない
ですから そこはこの 大変大事なポイントなんです
仏教の真理を語る場合
特に無常を説明する場合は
この無限因と言うんですかね
無間因とまあ言うかどうかわかりませんだけど
その無間因というのは大変大事なポイントなんですね
[背景の音楽]それはよく覚えておいた方がいいんです
それを理解すればもうかなりいろんな問題解決するんです
それはまた事実なんですね
一つの現象が消えることは次の現象の現れなんですね
それはずっと世の中であるんです
私たちにはこの理解できるのは物質の世界だけですけど
心も同じなんです 一つの心消えると次の心が現れる
ですから 次の心が現れるために必要な
どうしても必要な条件は前の心が消えることなんですね
同時に心二つがあるということにはないんです
そこはまあまあ理解できる事実ですね
感覚がないという まあそれはもう何を見たってわかることでね
まあ考えてのは この缶コーヒーを私は飲むと同時に
こう缶の中のコーヒーが減るということが思えるんです
空き缶になっていくんですね
で 飲むということと同時に
体にコーヒーが入るということは起きちゃうんですね
でも お腹に入るという現象から見れば感覚はあるかもしれませんだけど
それはもうもう一番身近な現象を忘れて遠い現象のことを考えてるんだからなんですね
お腹に入るということを考えてれば
それには時間かかっちゃうんですね
口からお腹に行くまでは
体に入ることを考えちゃうと
さらに時間かかるんですね
缶コーヒー飲んでからまあ十五分かかりますよね
十五分かかったらもうコーヒーが体に入りますよというふうにはなりますけど
でも そういう風にこの時間の過程をね
飛んで飛んで物のことを考えるんだから
事実はわからないんですね
だから世の中の人々は事実わからなくなっちゃうんです
飛ばさないで その瞬間のことだけ見ると
その人には事実見えてくるんですね
だから将来のことを考える人はただ馬鹿を見るだけで
事実から離れるだけなんです
例えば嘘は泥棒の始まりという言葉がありますね
で いや 嘘を言ったそれでその人は泥棒になったということじゃないでしょうね
だからそういう言葉にはなかなか真理性というのは信赖性というのは少ないんだから
子供にそれを言ったっても
全然もうあまり効かないんですね
冗談になっちゃうんですね
嘘は泥棒の始まりでね
ただ子供の遊ぶ言葉になってしまって
大事な道徳的な教えだよということはもうなくなっちゃうでしょ
なぜかというと 嘘をつく人は泥棒になる
嘘をつく原因で泥棒になるという原因結果喋ってますよ
そのことわざには 嘘は泥棒の始まりという言葉は
嘘を言う原因で泥棒という結果が現れますと
でもそれは正しい因縁の言葉じゃないんですね
なぜ正しくないかというと
その間ではすごい時間があるんですね
それからあの言ってない
見しゃるというか 交差してないものはすごいたくさんあるんです
それは全部省略しちゃうでしょう
省略して嘘は泥棒の始まりと
ですから 確実に嘘は泥棒の始まりじゃないんですね
だから正しく言うならば違う言葉になるだろうと思いますけどね
嘘を言って人を騙すと
で そこで人を騙すのは何のためかと
自分のために自分の都合によって人を騙してるんではない
そこで嘘はいつでも言えるんだからね
まあ平気で人を騙すことになっちゃうんだ
それからそれは欲の方につなげていくならば
自分を欲しいものをもらうと
そういうことにも嘘を使ってしまうと
それだったらもう自分欲しいものはまあもう勝手に取るということになって
嘘を言う人には簡単だと
ということであって 決して嘘は泥棒の始まりではないんです
嘘を言う人は その嘘を言うことは
やっぱりそういう欲に持っていけば泥棒になるかもしれませんね
だからちゃんとあの真理の真理っていうのは
ちゃんと原因と結果にすぐその場で現れる結果
それはもう確実な真理なんですね
間隔なしに結果が現れる
で それ理解してないんだからなんですね
人々はこの人間に魂があるんだというのも
で 例えばこの触れることなく自分の心をずっと回転しているんですね
心は止まったという経験は誰にもないんです
それではずっと小さい時から私がいたんじゃないかと
錯覚するんですね 小さい時からいたのは私ですよと
それで私という何かあるんだと
そういうのはアヨーニソーマヌシカーラとパーリ語で言うんですね
因果法則を無視しているんだと
因果法則を無視している
だから因果法則如実に考えることじゃないんだと
ヨーニソーマヌシカーラというのは如実にという考えるということで
アヨーニソーマヌシカーラっていうのはその反対で
ですから如実に考えると
あるのまま考えると まあ我っていうものは成り立たなくなっちゃうんだと
で ですから そこら辺にあるこの問題というのは
この無限因果 という問題なんですね
一つの心が消えると瞬間
次の心が現れてくるんですね
どんな心にもその瞬間
自分という気持ちがあるんだからね
私が悲しがっているという気持ちがあるし
私が楽しいと ですから
この瞬間瞬間 私 私という実感が生まれてくるんだから
そこに間隔ないんだから
間がないんだから いっぺん一つだと
思ってしまう じゃあ次に行きます
サマナンタラパッチヤ
あ サマナンタラパッチヤに行く前にちょっと言い忘れたことがあります
アナンタラパッチヤの場合は
これは条件ですからね
だからこれなんで条件と使うかっていうことはちょっとわかりませんですけどね
で 物事の変化はそのように変化するんですね
これ変化の仕方なんですね
物事は変化する場合 一つ変化すると一つの現象を変化すると
次の現象は確実に現れる
それはもう止まることは誰にもできません
紙を燃やしたら灰になる
それはもう止まることはできません
間がない 同時でもないんだけど
やっぱり次に起こると
次というとただの言葉で時間の感覚がない
だから時間の感覚なければ同時ではないかということ
また違うんですね 同時でなければ
やっぱり時間の隔たりがあるんじゃないかというふうに
もう頭で考えるかもしれません
頭で考えても なんかちょっと言葉だけではちょっと理解しにくいんですね
間がないだけしか言えないんですね
紙が燃える 灰が現れる
だから紙が燃えるっていうこと自体が灰が現れるっていうことになる
これ 言葉だけ持っていっちゃうと
ルージュみたいに長寿みたいに
これは否定しなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
紙が現れると同時に灰が現れるということは
時間の感覚ないということでしょうと
そうすると 紙と灰が同じ時間で紙が燃えることと灰が現れることは同じ時間ではないかと
ということは 紙がある時も灰もあるということでしょうと
それはありえないでしょうと
ここに紙があって 紙 1枚があって
ここにまた灰もありますよということはありえないんだからね
だからこんなパッチェーがありえませんと否定しちゃうんですね
ルージュ中論勉強している方々は
そういうところは明確に知っているだろうと思いますけどね
そういうのは単なる言葉の遊びです
中論というのは言葉で遊んでいるんですね
確かに言葉で遊んじゃうとそうなっちゃうんですね
すごくへ理屈になってしまっちゃうんですね
私たちから見れば もう灰があると紙がないし
経験ではね だから紙が先にあって
それから灰があるんじゃないかということになっちゃうんですね
それもルージュがまたからかっちゃうんですね
言葉で そこへ行ったらどこまでするかわからないんだから
とにかく 間がないということで生まれるんだ
だからこれは条件として見ているんですね
別に条件間がないということは条件にはならないんですね
よく考えると それ条件にはならないんです
事実であることは事実なんです
物事を見ると 心の働きを見ると
やっぱり間がなく変化していくんですね
止まることなく すべてのものはずっと変化しているんですね
だからすごく不思議なんですけどね
人が足を上げて歩くと
だから足を上げて前に持っていくことと
人が前に進むことは結局間がないんです
歩けますといえばね 足を上げて前に持っていって下ろすということだけですけどね
だから一つの足を下ろすと次に次の足を上げることは起こるんで起こるんですね
だからその働きなんだけど
ヴィパッサナー瞑想でやらせるというのは
なぜならば このサティで確認してやるとなかなかやりにくいんですね
なぜやりにくいかと これちょっと頭をきれいな頭でオープンな頭で見たら
そこに真理の世界があるんですね
やりにくいんだから 何か簡単にやれる方法はないかと私に聞くんだからね
そこで教えるバカもいるんで
こうすれば簡単ですよと
私は簡単な方法を教えないと
私に対してすごく腹が立つんですね
機嫌が悪いとかね いい加減だとかね
親切じゃないんだとかね
何かしつれなことを言うだろうとか
そんなことなんもない
私にとって何の感情もないんですけどね
私は目覚めてほしいだけ
だから簡単にやれる方法はないかと
教えはあげませんね まあそれも人の
まあそのその人の心の状況の場合だけど
ものすごい混乱状態で
でもう頭がもう妄想だらけで
もう真理見える暇がないならば
いくらか心に余裕が現れるようにと色々工夫は教えてあげます
それは心に余裕が現れるためだけなんですね
右足を下ろして 次にもう左足が上げちゃうんですね
間がないんです 一つの現象終わったということは
次の現象は現れたということなんですね
これは同時かと聞くのは良くないんです
同時じゃないんです 同時だったらありえないんですね
右足を下ろすことと同時に左足で上げるんだというと歩けないんです
じゃあ時間かかるかというと
歩く場合は止まったりすることできますから
まあまあ それまあ時間かかる
あれなんとか言います
例えば早歩きする場合は
もう右足下ろすともう左足が上げてるんですね
それで早歩きして瞑想しちゃうと
一つ下ろすとこれ上げてるっていうこと
時間なく感覚なくさっさと上げていくんだっていうことがわかっちゃうんです
それで時間の感覚ないんだから
時間かかってないはずなんでしょ？でも時間かかってるんです
そこら辺は論理の世界じゃないんです
だからすごい早く歩く場合は
右足を下ろすともう左足が上げてるんです
だからこうやったん こんな感じだから
例えばコンパスで考えると
そういう風にも動いてるんですね
それだったら時間がないでしょ
取ってないんだから それだったら百メートル歩いたっての一秒もかかってないはずなんですね
でも 百メートル歩く場合はやっぱり五分間ぐらいかかってる可能性はあります
五分間かかりませんけど
私の場合 五分間かかったというならば
やっぱり時間感覚はありますけど
でもかえって感覚はまた帰ってないんですね
ですから そういうのはこの実証論だから
実際にそう起こるんです
起こるんですね ですから
時間計算とかね なかなか難しいもんなんです
で 紙 紙 1枚と灰の例えに戻って考えちゃう
やっぱり 全部灰になるという現象を見ちゃうと
三秒かかりましたとかね
あるいはまあ二十秒かかりましたとか
時間は計れますね でも瞬間の出来事を見ると時間は計れません
計れませんだけど だったら時間ないってことなんですけど
でも結局時間の経過もそちらにあるんです
だからそこら辺にはこのアビダンマは論理的に喋ってるんだけど
そちらでやっぱり論理では言葉
普通の人間の考え方ではいかないなということはもう明確に
見えるはずなんです それで
これなんで条件というでしょうかね
だからこれ条件でいうのは
例えば前の現象があって
次の現象が生まれると
という間の場合 場合は前の現象が消えると同時にっていうのはちょっと言葉だけなんです
同時にかどうかはわかりませんだけど
無間的に次の現象が現れるんです
ですから 火が得るためには無間ということは条件だというふうに言ってるんです
因と果の間は無間という間がないという
無間か無間かどちらでしょうか
どちらの まあどちらも使いますけど
無間という条件ですよ
無間だから生まれますよ
だからこれは本当は条件としてはちょっと強引すぎなんですが
その現象自体が その働き自体は確実にあるんです
無間という働き この条件論を喋る場合は
これも結構結構強引に条件にしている
そんな条件は必要ないんです
そのように現れて消えて現れて消えていっちゃうんです
それは仏教の世界で この考え方
このいろいろ続けていって
例えばこの今の我々の心の状況を見ると
心が瞬間瞬間現れては消える
現れては消える 現れては消える
それはまず大雑把に理解する
例えば  2つのことを一同に妄想できません
瞬間妄想するのは一つのことなんですね
それ消えるとそれに関係ある次の妄想が生まれるんですね
で 次にそれ消えるとそれに関係ある次の妄想が生まれる
だからって だからって人が一方のこともしてるわけじゃない
いろんなくだらないことを
いろんな余計なことを妄想していますけど
やっぱりどこかでつなげてるんですね
どこかでつなげて 妄想というのはいろんな枝分かれて枝分かれていくんですね
そこで時間のこの感覚なしに生まれることを気づいてないんだからね
同時に 2つのことを考えたとかね
いろんなことを考え 妄想していたとかという錯覚は起こりますけどね
瞬間ではやっぱりそういうふうなものじゃない
ずっと  なんて言いますか
1つ妄想して 次のことを妄想して
それが終わったら次のことに
そこで一秒間 二秒間 何を申せたかというと
これは様々なことを申せたかもしれませんだけど
そこそちらにはやっぱりちゃんとつながりがあるんです
ですから それを理解するためには
あくまでも自分のことを客観化しなくちゃいけないんですね
客観化 客観化していくということ
どんどんどんどんどんどんわかっていくんですね
うん まあ考えてみればそこら辺はすごい難しいんです
理解するのは そこで言いたがっているのは
この そういうことで 心は一つ消えると次の心が生まれるでしょうと
一つの妄想が消えると次の妄想が生まれるでしょうと
例えば真剣に瞬間でも膨らみと観察すると
その瞬間に妄想がないんです
ああ寒いとも感じないんです
それだけ見ると そういうわけで
別に集中力っていうのはそんなにすごく必要というわけでもないんだけど
集中力あった方がその法則は分かりやすいんですね
集中力あって 本当に集中して膨らみとその感覚を感じていると
他の何も考えない 考えられない
だから痛みなんか出てきたらさっさと痛みを観察しなさいというのは
これは主縁だから いろんな対象の中で痛みっていうのは主縁でしょうに
だから自分をごまかして騙して
私は痛み 痛みあっても膨らみ縮みだけ見ているんだとかね
かっこつけたっても それは意味がないんですね
主縁だから この主縁を確認すると
そこら辺で集中力は生まれてくるんです
ですから 痛みはじっと痛みそのものを観察しちゃうと妄想もないんです
寒いとかね ああだこうだとか出てこない
で その時 まあ智慧がある人に
いわゆる智慧があるということは
このオープンな心があるっていう意味なんで
心がオープンだったら
やっぱり瞬間は一つのことしかやってないんだと
心っていうのはね わかるんですね
だから一つ見ると他のことは見てないんだと
だから瞬間瞬間 心は一つだけ見ているんだっていうことは発見できる
それで心は止まることがないんだと
これを見て次のことを見る
それを見て次のことを見る
それを見て次のことを見るという働きだよということもわかってくるんですね
そう そこで何が理解するかって
やっぱり永遠に等しいっていうことはありえないんだと
永遠っていうのはありえないっていうことがわかるんです
だから我々永遠というのは同じものの繰り返しなんですね
同じものを生滅変化し続けると
それはよくあるものだと思う
また勘違いする すべて勘違いなんです
世の中の知識っていうのは
まあわかりやすく例で見てください
例えば蛍光灯の光があるでしょう
我々はまあずっと蛍光灯はずっともう何時間も光ってるんだと思っちゃいますけど
それなぜそう思うかというと
同じ現象を繰り返してるんだからなんですね
本当は電子 電子一個触れたら蛍光灯の薬に
それはもう光る それで電子が消えますから
それで光も消える 次のまた似ている電子がぶつかるんだから
似ている光が現れる 似ているものずっと続くんだから
蛍光灯っていうのは一年間でも使えますよということを言うんだ
だから寿命は一年間ですよと
もしそれは百年だったら
これは百年間持ちますよと
もし同じ現象がもう一億年続くならば
もう一億年も続きますよと
同じもの続きますよと言っちゃうんです
だから我々は人間より鉄の方がもう寿命長いんだとかね
我々よりは地球の方が長生きしているんだとか
錯覚しているんじゃないんですか
それ全て錯覚なんです
地球も私たちと同じスピードで変化していくんです
ただ 問題は 人間の体は同じ現象で変化しない
石一つ見たら変化はするんだけど
前と同じなんですね 蛍光灯の光で考えてみてください
瞬間前の光と今の瞬間の光は似ていますから
光ってるんだと言っちゃうんですね
次の瞬間の光も似ているんだから同じだと思っちゃいます
だから似ていることで永遠という錯覚が生まれるんですね
でも変化の速さはすべてのものは同じなんです
もし似てないならば 我々は無常だ
変化するんだということに驚くんですね
だって紙 1枚を燃やしちゃうと灰になるでしょうし
だから紙と灰っていうのは全く似てないんですね
全く似てないんだから
やっぱり変化するんだ
無常だと そこで鉄の塊を見て無常だとは思うないんですね
紙 1枚見て無常だと思わないんですね
それは同じ速さで変化しているんです
問題は今の瞬間変化して次に現れる瞬間の現象もほとんど似ているんだから
ですから この無限因というのはもう大変大事な考え方なんです
アビダンマのおかしいところは
これすごい条件づけているだけのことで
条件なんか要りませんですけど
このアナンタラという言葉っていうのはすごい発見です
間がない だからそれを推測してみて
さらに推測能力を働かせちゃうと
心が止まることないんだから
死んだら止まると いうことは不可能になっちゃうんですね
自分でわからないんだけど
止まれないはずでしょうと
止まったストップということはないでしょう
世の中で何も ストップというものはありえません
消えるということはありますけど
消えると他の現象が現れるんですね
そこでストップ 全部停止と
ということはないんです
ずっと無限因で変化していくんですね
そういうわけで 死ぬ瞬間で心はストップ
もう終わった ということは言えないでしょうと
それは因果法則には逆らっているんだと